خرجت في العاصمه الالمانيه برلين مظاهرات
دعت اليها منظمات وجمعيات فلسطينيه
والمانيه ودعى المتحدثون في المظاهره
الحكومه الالمانيه الى التحرك لوقف ما
سموه الاباده الجماعيه التي ترتكبها
اسرائيل في غزه من ساحه بوتسدام وسط برلين
ينضم الينا عيسى الطيبه عيسى انقل لنا
الاجواء وبالطبع هذه ليست المظاهره الاوى
الاولى الداعمه لفلسطين والرافضه للحرب
الاسرائيليه على قطاع غزه في المانيا
هذه المظاهره هي الموجه الثانيه من
المظاهرات التي تشهدها العاصمه الالمانيه
وتشهدها المدن الالمانيه وهي تصعيديه
بمعنى انها الان اصبحت بشكل نهائي تضم
اطياف متعدده سواء من الناشطين الالمان او
من الجمعيات وخصوصا بعد
انضمام حركه
الاسرائيليين الرافضين للحرب اليها طبعا
مع الصوت اليهودي مع غير من المنظمات هذا
الزخم الجديد ايضا بانضمام مجموعات من
الناشطه من الاوروبيين نتحدث من ايرلندا
من ايطاليا وغيرها لذلك الزخم الجديد لهذه
المظاهره زخم نوعي بحيث انه اصبح الان
يتماشى مع المظاهرات الالمانيه التي تدعو
ايضا الى الى وقف فوري لهذه الحرب وايضا
تدعو الحكومه الالمانيه المستشار تحديدا
الى ان يتحرك لما سموه الاباده عيه هذا
التوصيف اصبح الان توصيفا مباشرا واضحا
متلازما في المظاهرات الالمانيه حاولت بعض
الاصوات ان ترفض هذا التصريح ورفع الدعاوه
في القضاء الالماني ضد هذه الشعارات
المرفوعه في المظاهرات لكن المحاكم قضت في
مرتين متتاليتين لصالح الناشطين الفلسطيني
والداعمين الالمان لهم هذه المظاهره ايضا
ليست جديده من حيث ايضا انها تتناول مساله
الاسرى تتحدث الان على ان هذه النقطه على
هذه الهدنه في في قطاع غزه تبادل الاسر
ايضا يتحدثون بان الاسرى الفلسطينيين ايضا
هم جزء من هذه الفقاعه يتحدثون ايضا بان
القيادات الاسرائيليه ونرى ونشاهد ايضا
الصور كثير من القاده الاسرائيليين خصوصا
القاده العسكريين و رفعت في هذه المظاهره
التي تعتبرهم مجرم حرب وايضا تعتبرهم
بانهم يرتكبون اعمال اباده جماعيه في غزه
الامر الاخر الذي ركز عليه المتحدثون هنا
شكرا
ما ال مره
حقوق القانون الاساسي في المانيا عيس
الطيب مرس الجزيره في برلين من وسط هذه
التظاهر شكرا لك